SPEAKER: In our
last two episodes,
we learned how to
manage GK infrastructure
and the individual
services running on it.
But as our applications
become more complex,
more services are involved
in serving user traffic
and completing transactions.
It then becomes more and
more critical to understand
how requests traverse
multiple services
and how each service
contributes to overall latency.
This is what distributed
tracing does.
It captures the latency
of user requests
and how long it takes
each service in the path
to return response.
Today, I'm going to show
you how to capture latency
in distributed applications
using OpenTelemetry
and analyze it
using Cloud Trace.
Welcome to "Engineering for
Reliability" with Google Cloud.
Let's start by reviewing the
basics of distributed tracing.
These were originally described
in Google's research paper
on the Dapper distributed
tracing framework.
We'll link to it below
if you'd like to read it.
When a user request
comes in, we want
to create a trace
that'll describe
how our system responds.
Traces are composed of spans
where each span represents
a specific request and response
pair involved in serving
the original user request.
The parent span describes a
latency as observed by the end
user.
Each of the child
spans describes
how a particular service
in a distributed system
was called and responded with
latency information captured
for each.
Now, let's take a look
at a basic example.
We have a front-end service
that responds to user requests
and makes calls to
a back-end service.
It has to wait on
that back-end call
to complete to return the
response back to the user.
We want to trace
this interaction
to understand both total latency
and latency in each service.
We recommend that
you use OpenTelemetry
for distributed tracing.
It's an open-source
project that provides
a single set of APIs, libraries,
agents, and collector services
to capture distributor
traces and metrics
from your application.
Let's have a look
at how to instrument
your code for tracing.
We'll also link to the full code
sample in the episode notes.
We start by sending up
the Cloud Trace exporter.
This will let us
send the traces we
collect to Cloud Trace for
inspection and analysis.
In the front-end
code, we start tracing
and create the root span.
We then make a request
to the back end
with the appropriate context.
This is data embedded
in the HTTP headers
that our back end
can use to append
subsequent spans to our traits.
In the back-end code,
we extract the context
from the incoming request
to create additional spans.
This allows us to
explicitly measure
the latency of our
back-end servers
and create custom spans
if, for example, we
want to time how long specific
back-end tests might take.
Now, let's run the code
and have a look at how
we can use Cloud Trace
to inspect request
latency for both incoming user
requests and back-end calls.
From the project dashboard,
let's go to the Products menu
and select Trace.
The trace list shows
us all the traces
that have been captured in our
project over the selected time
interval.
Let's switch that
to the last day.
Then, let's filter
for the traces
for just incoming requests
for our front-end service
using the label that
we set in our code.
Next, let's select a relevant
trace from the resulting list.
This shows us the
waterfall chart
with the parent span
at the top and all
of the child spans below that.
We can see the
latency for each span
in the chart to
quickly determine
the source of the latency
in our application overall.
To get more information,
we can enable events.
These are annotations
we've added in our code
to more easily
understand exactly
what's happening at each span.
Finally, we can click on any of
the spans to get details for it
over here on the right.
This is how we can use
Cloud Trace to analyze
both the overall
latency of user requests
and how they
traverse our services
to find the primary
contributors to latency issues.
Thanks for joining me today.
We covered the basics
of distributor tracing
and saw how to use
OpenTelemetry to collect traces.
We then saw how to use
Cloud Trace to inspect
traces and analyze latency.
I hope this helps you
keep your services fast
and your users happy.
Thanks so much for watching.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more "Engineering for
Reliability" with Google Cloud.
See you soon.
[MUSIC CHORDS]